The kind of connection to the proper, the authentic, and those sorts of things leads
itself to a fascism.
I'm wondering what the other commitment lends itself to.
The sort of non-recognition would be, that's the word that I've always used, the sense
of non-recognition or disidentification.
What does that lend itself towards?
Because I don't think it's fascism.
The typical fear is laissez-faire, right?
Right.
Yeah.
That would be the, like, anything goes...
Or, like, schizo, you know, kind of like just total disidentification to the point of, like,
paranoia and, you know, that kind of thing.
I mean, Deleuze even writes about that as a possibility, as a potentiality of that situation.
But I don't think fascism doesn't arise from that.
I think if that's the condition of possibility for life, then fascism would have to be a part
of that dynamic as well, right?
Or a possibility.
So, but I mean, you'd have to have...
I mean, because paranoia strikes me as directly leading to a kind of fascism, right?
You know, it's that sense of, like, I'm constantly under threat by the other.
Because you want to collect.
Yeah, you want to...
Yeah, like, I have to...
So, I could see it.
But it's the sense of disidentification or non-recognition is, like, really, don't know...
Not knowing who you are.
That's the thing that I wrote on Ecce Homo.
It's like, that's...
Become what you are means becoming is what you are.
Not figure out who you really are and get there, right?
I mean, ideally, it would lead to some version of empathy.
Like, not in the traditional sense, I guess.
But, like, just in the fact that if you don't know who you are, and if you're allowing for
that kind of, like, real ambiguity into the fabric of your being, then you don't know
who anyone else is either.
Yeah, yeah, no, but that, like, there's something important, because I know that I've, at least
in terms of the field, like, my relationship to the field, like, I know that I've felt
that, like, frustration and irritation at, like, not being sufficiently recognized and
wanting...
And then there is a flip side of me that's, like, there's actually a lot of freedom in
the position of not being an important person in the field, right?
Like, that I don't have to speak for a position.
Like, Judith Butler, like, I just, to me, she's the paradigmatic case.
Like, I can't imagine...
This is one of the quotes that the woman said last night, which I thought was great, that
Butler said that she attempts to live at some distance from her name.
And I thought that was a really interesting way of thinking of the non-recognition thing,
that she has to live at a distance from Judith Butler.
The institution.
Right, like, the institution that is myself, you know, at that case.
Like, that level, like, whenever you speak, you are always speaking for.
And, my God, like, the extraordinary...
Because I don't even think I'm speaking for myself when I speak, when I write stuff.
I don't feel that way, you know?
And I have in the past, but I decreasingly feel that way.
And there's an extraordinary freedom that's available in not knowing who I am and who I'm
supposed to be or being interpolated into these various subject positions.
Right, yeah.
I mean, I like to think of that orientation as leading sort of toward a kind of tinkering.
You know, constantly, like, constantly, you know, playing with what can be made from this
or that thing.
But the more...
But, you know, like, I think it can, you know, it's sort of like thinking about the sort
of risks of that orientation.
It seems like some kind of alienation rare...
Alienation through rarefaction, you know, is precisely a danger there is that as you sort
of, like, producing less and less recognizable material that, you know, you can kind of follow
the chain of thoughts.
But it's kind of...
I mean, you know, we find this all the time.
It's like fucking hard to talk to, increasingly hard to talk to people about everyday things,
you know, when you sort of, like, follow the rabbit hole down this particular path.
And let's keep in mind that fascism has its own modality of rarefaction.
Like, purity is nothing but a rarefaction that, you know, refining, perpetual refining to
the point...
Now, that's, like, a perpetual refining to the point where, you know, nothing exists
anymore, and that's its kind of...
Yeah.
Right.
I don't know.
I just feel like...
Well, I mean, to go back to the Butler thing real quick, just...
Like, she has to literally act as a representative.
And this kind of ties into what we're saying.
Like, so her work...
She's interpolated into the position.
It's not like she, you know...
Right, right.
She didn't really choose it, but...
Right.
That directly affects the way you think and the way you write.
Because...
It has to.
And you can see it.
Her work has become less experimental.
That's right.
Less adventurous, I would say.
And more position-taking.
Position-taking.
It's still pretty...
It's still rigorous.
It's still very careful.
Yeah.
It's still smart.
But it's not as promiscuous, to use one of your words.
No, that's good.
Right.
It's not as conceptually adventurous.
And that's because of the constraints of her position.
It's a political position.
When you're a representative...
That's right.
You can't write like Zizek.
Right.
Because of the success of her thinking, she can't think anymore.
So, yeah.
I mean, so in a sense, like...
That's an exaggeration.
That kind of...
The thing that allowed her to become what she is has now hamstrung her.
That's right.
Which is very...
It's kind of unfortunate.
I just love the locution of that she feels that she has to live at some distance from her name.
That is really...
Yeah, that's good.
Yeah.
And she chooses they, by the way.
That's her pronoun.
Yeah.
Well, that might be a political decision as well.
I'm sure...
Yeah.
I'm certain that it is.
In fact, the quote was from her, which pronoun she uses, they, you know, is, they would be
the most accurate.
And it's, for me, it was the word, the most accurate, that I was like, accuracy?
That's the question of the pronoun?
Like, I didn't think accuracy.
But I understand politically, like, I understand politically why accuracy.
It's like, these words don't fit, this word fits, as opposed to, I'm going to try this
word out.
Like, it's not a very good political, it just doesn't have its political efficacy.
But I'm not in a position, I'm in a position where I can say that.
Like, okay, let's try this pronoun out.
Right?
Like, and because who the fuck cares?
Nobody cares what Muckelbauer says about his pronoun or their pronoun.
You know what I mean?
No one gives a shit.
Yeah.
So there's an advantage to being unimportant.
For sure.
And there's a, there's a, I mean, fascism structurally, not politically.
There's a fascism to, like, occupying a political position in the sense that you're having to
collect all these things under an umbrella that you wouldn't have to otherwise, right?
Like you were saying, you have a, you're in a relative position of freedom when you write
and when you think, because you're not acting as a representative.
And when you're in the position that Butler has adopted, there's almost, it's, it's, it's
a, it's a collecting impulse.
It's a fascist impulse that kind of organizes the social field, regardless of the actual political
contingency involved.
So, I mean, everybody, this is a tired point, but like, there's a fascism of progressivism,
you know, and, but there is, I mean, there is, there's a team-based kind of like, you
know, tribal thinking that goes on in each of these years.
And she has to negotiate that, however, she does, I mean, you know, we don't know her
personally, but like, but, but here's the thing, we're all negotiating that in different
ways at different levels.
I mean, she just has a sort of public eye in ways that we, we don't, but we're still,
I mean, it's the very question that you're negotiating in terms of your relation to Barad
is the big picture one, but also you relate, those smaller ones, it's Davis, Boyle, Deleuze,
right?
Like those other, those other figures that we're trying to figure out, like, how do I
situate myself in relation?
And it's like, well, you have to presume you have a self first and that that matters.
What's, what's interesting about Butler currently is that, um, her new book is, is that like
the politics of nonviolence or something.
It's like, and it's so Hegelian and she mentions Hegel once.
She's completely abandoned Hegel from her like citational, you know, pool.
Um, but the book is so overtly Hegelian.
So strategically she must be thinking Hegel doesn't, is not relevant for my kind of scholarship.
He's not going to sell books.
He's not, he's not a feminist.
There's nothing, you know, really relevant, uh, but, but the actual philosophy itself,
what the book should be called is a politics of violence, because all she talks about is
violence and the capacity for human violence in the very fabric of relations.
So while she's pushing for something else, right?
This kind of ethical move, like past violence.
All she's saying is that constitutively we are as a people inherently violent.
And can't, and can't not be.
And can't not be, yeah.
As life.
Right, right.
Life itself is violent.
But that's okay.
Like, I don't, that doesn't, I mean, I've always thought of her as being Hegelian.
I mean, her dissertation was on Hegelian.
Like, I've always thought of her as being Hegelian.
No, I know.
No, it's just funny that, like, she's had to kind of move past him, at least from, like, a marketing
perspective.
I don't know.
It's like.
But also sort of a thinking person.
Like, for instance, in my, in the style book, I don't think I've cited Deleuze once.
Right?
Like, it's not, it's certainly not intentional.
It's just like, well, that's, that stuff is just pretty fundamental to how I think.
It's not.
Yeah.
That's true.
It could be that.
It's not something that I'm necessarily talking about.
Right.
So you never know.
It could be that.
That would be the more, that would be the more generous.
Right.
Yeah.
It's like, this is just the terrain of my thinking.
It's not something that you could cite like a quote.
It's just how I think.
So, I mean, I thought that way.
I will also say, I thought that way about Nietzsche for a long time.
I remember when I first taught the very first class on Nietzsche that I taught and it felt
because I had not taught, I had not talked about Nietzsche other than the truth and lies
I say, like, ever.
And it was for that exact reason is because this thinking just felt so close to me that I
didn't want to cite it because that just seemed like that's ridiculous.
That's so small and puny.
Like this is the terrain or milieu of how I think.
And, and over the last decade since I did that, I now have a different kind of relationship
with Nietzsche where I still think.
That was a decade ago?
Oh my God.
Yeah.
It was.
I still think that, I mean, I still think that it is the terrain and milieu of my thinking,
but I can talk about it in ways now.
Like I'm not there with Deleuze.
Deleuze is just such a terrain for my thinking that I can't really talk about it because it,
it just seems wrong.
And I also don't want to, it seems so partitioned to say like, I'm going to talk about a chunk
of Deleuze or something like, I don't want to do like, you know, The Logic, I wasn't
in favor of doing The Logic of Sense, you know, which is weird, right?
Like I'm supposed to be Deleuze boy.
Okay.
So if you wanted to say, you know, there's only difference in identity and they're at
work with each other, then that would be to, to reify, I think that would be to, to do
too much of privileging the side of identity, right?
Because, you know, there are only two things, right?
But I think that you could arrive at this particular kind of plurality, a particular kind of like
constant tension through a prior monism of pure movement.
of that, you know, there is nothing that is essentially substantial.
There's only the making substantial through, you know, force on force interaction, but the
provisional making nominal of something is constitutive of, of movement.
And so like, there is no, it's, it's only, and, and, you know, I don't think that.
Hold on a second.
You would say that's what movement is, is the provisional making nominal of something.
Yes.
Right.
Like that, that is what movement is.
Yeah.
So, so there's, so that's where, to me, you have, that's a difference.
You don't have two forces warring with one another.
You have one force sort of.
That self-differentiates.
That self-differentiates, right?
Like, yeah.
So, that, that to me, it just feels very different.
But reactive force, I, but this is, I always, I've always had, like, literally from the very
first reading group I did with you on Nietzsche and Philosophy in your old apartment, like
how many ever years ago, I've always had a certain issue with, of, of imagining thinking
and consciousness solely in terms of reactive force.
And it's like, that's reactive force and everything else is active force.
And like, think about a, like a supposedly non-human encounter of like a bird building a nest
or a wolf eating a sheep, you know, there is an active reactive set of relationships there
as well.
Like, the, like does not the bird nominalize in some ways the nest provisionally does not
the wolf nominal, nominalize or, you know, uh, um, uh, um, make an object out of, of the
sheep.
And then doesn't the reaction of the sheep, you know, like, I don't know, bleeding or whatever
else, a series of reactive forces that sort of continue to concretize a, a provisional
momentary, um, um, relationship.
Like that doesn't seem to me to be just an act of consciousness or thinking.
And frankly, it doesn't have to be caught.
It doesn't have to be consciousness.
It doesn't have to be.
That's just the sort of terminology.
Like I'm, I'm okay with that, but I, I still would say there, you know, active force
confronting active force, right?
Cause it's never just a, you know, it's never just one active force, like, but active force
Produces reactions.
Like, like de-territorialization produces re-territorializations.
Only one of which we call consciousness.
Yeah, that's fine.
I mean, I'm, I'm, I'm fine with that.
Consciousness doesn't have to be the uber one.
It just tends to, consciousness does.
I mean, look, just even how you frame the question, it's like, imagine a wolf doing this
and it's like, okay, well, we've already nominalized these things and then considered
them an action.
And that's fine.
Like that's, I don't have a problem with that.
That's, that's okay.
But that's just one thing among others in terms of, uh, in terms of what's happening, you
know, in, in, the, the scene of that kind, I feel like you can say there's only active
force and there are just the sort of residual reactions of formations called the wolf, called
the nest, called the, whatever the things are that we're talking about.
Like nest building would be, you know, the constitutive active force that constitutes both the bird
and the nest, right?
You would have to say something like that.
Yeah, that's right.
And so for instance, like, and let me just say, like, even when you do the thing that he
does with, um, you know, the, the section that we just talked about, the noun and the
verbing of the, the, what participles get you, right?
It's something interesting about that.
Even still, he wants to say for the noun, which is the present, right?
That that's the present version.
This is right.
Even for the noun, we still have to show that verbing or action.
Like that's the, still the thing that's missing.
Like to me on, on 236, this question of presence that you guys were talking about when I logged
on initially, um, but this rise from unconcealment as the entry into what is unconcealed does
not specifically come to the fore in the presence of what is present.
It is part of presence to hold back these traits and thus to let come out only that which
is present.
So presence in that sense, what presence gives you, the nominal eyes is it gives you the things
there.
The tree is there.
The mountain is there.
All these things are right.
Um, what it doesn't give you is the coming to fore of the presence, right?
It doesn't give you the entry into unconcealment of the presence.
In other words, it doesn't give you the active force or the movement, which is, so in other,
that's where I'm saying like, he's, he wants to hang on to the simultaneity of the noun
and the verb, except for the noun is verbed.
Right.
So it's like, so why hold on to this simultaneity?
When in fact, it seems to me like the direction here is saying, go verb, like go to the verb.
Well, or, or you would, or there's just different speeds of verbs and you know, like one way
of saying that active reactive force, they're not, you know, different kinds of force.
They're just, you know, one force is only ever slowing down another force.
Right.
And then, so like a noun is only ever slower moving verb.
That's fine.
I'd be super comfortable with that because what does it, what one doesn't have there is a
Hegelian dialectic.
Yeah.
Right.
Like one doesn't get that then one gets a kind of monism that residually has Hegel.
In other words, it is like, you know, everything that occurs in the Hegelian milieu will be
right, but only as an epiphenomenon of active force.
And I think you get that in his critique of the concept is that, you know, like in his critique
of the dialectic and his, in his, his critique of, of the concept is that, you know, that,
that sort of, um, movement is only possible within a very particular realm.
But that realm is again, this sort of like sub species or this sort of offshoot of something
a little bit more originary.
It's like, you know, this moment of thinking shot off a particular thing that we'll call
rational understanding.
And Hegel did a really fucking good job of diagnosing the way that that little thread
runs.
But it's one thread of a bunch of other stuff and it doesn't, and it's not nearly as inescapable
as Hegel imagines it.
It's only inescapable if you confine yourself to a human consciousness and human understanding.
And I would agree.
And I would agree with that.
And I would say, and that would be the importance of Hegel, right?
Like, and that would be saying like, look, here's, I mean, that's a way of saying Hegel's
not wrong.
Yeah.
But he's also not right.
You know, he's right in a particular milieu.
Yeah.
He's very right about a thread, right?
About a machine.
Which is a, which is a really big fucking machine.
Yeah.
It's a really big, we'll call it, you know, the vast majority of, you know.
I mean, for Hegel, it's the only machine.
So that, that would be the difference between him and Deleuze is that Deleuze is positing
a primary vital force or a primordial flow of desire or whatever part of his language you
want to use that is beneath primary to, constitutive of subjectivity and representational thinking.
But that's not, that's just one of its offshoots, right?
It can enable physical life, et cetera, anything besides the subject.
And this is where, this is where I think Derrida, if we pick the right essays or the right combination
of essays, he will be an interesting fulcrum on which to think these two kind of modes of
thought.
Because in some, in a lot of places, he leans towards the Deleuzean orientation where he's
kind of an ontological thinker, right?
The trace lends itself that way.
But then, difference also is equally invested in subjective aporia.
As it is in, like, material difference, right?
So it's like, almost like he's playing both sides or he's attempting to throughout his career,
like play the Deleuze and play the Hegel and like, you know, see what complexity, right?
Well, and he certainly got, he certainly got taken up in that sort of subjective aporetic
sense, primarily first, right?
And one still has to make the argument for, like, you have to, it's not just a given that
Derrida is a materialist thinker.
Right, right.
Or even an ontological thinker.
Like, it's, that's not a given.
That was work that was done.
Yeah.
Right, right.
Over the last 20 years, you know.
Right.
Yeah.
Or I guess longer now.
In part, I feel like that is coming out of his Heideggerian, right?
Like, I mean, one of the things that appeals to me about Deleuze is he sort of starts from
a kind of, a sense of Nietzschean movement is like, I mean, I was just thinking, I was
thinking several minutes ago in the course of our conversation, like we had a great little
exchange there and it's literally not going to be hearable by anyone who hasn't read very
specific books, right?
Not just like, right, like they're, like, I mean, it's got to be Phenomenology of Spirit.
It's got to be Deleuze's book on Nietzsche.
It's got to be The Genealogy of Morals.
It's got to be Heidegger, Washeiß-Denken, and Being in Time.
Like, no, it's that, that like 10 minute exchange we had, unless the person has read
these five books and like in a particular way.
Yeah.
I was just going to say this, this episode is for Thomas, but then you, like, I mean,
you know, for instance, there's just an incredibly small number of people that I think would have
any would follow that at all, like including us.
Yeah.
But there's us, there's like, you know, Neelan.
We're not really the Taylor Swift of like philosophy podcasts.
You know, we're not a common denominator.
You know, it's, it's, it's all over the place.
Very specific milieus that only we have entered into.
Right.
Like we had that whole conversation using Deleuzian terminology without specifically reference
that we were using Deleuzian terminology.
It never, it never, we didn't miss a beat.
Well, thank God Thinking With has already done a season on Hegel and on Deleuze.
Don't be caught up.
We really need to do on Nietzsche after, I think Nietzsche has to be after Derrida.
Yeah, for sure.
I was thinking that.
I was thinking like, we actually do need to do Nietzsche.
Well, because it's so fun.
It's funny because we've been doing, we've been doing German, French, German, French.
Yeah.
And then we do Nietzsche after Derrida, we'll go back to German.
There we go.
I didn't even think of that.
Right, right.
So that is our Satanist difference.
Satanist difference.
Yeah.
But, but I do, I do, because for me, when he gets to the Toe Auto right at the end, the
last year, that's, that's what you missed is the toe, or you got right at the beginning
of the, the Toe Auto.
Like that's the place, given what I'm working on right now, obviously, right?
The style question is, can you say the same thing in a different way, right?
Like that, the question of sameness and difference is absolutely constitutive, right?
Like that is the problem.
And the resolution that I am constantly bumping up against that I'm not satisfied with is
there are forces of sameness and forces of difference, and they are at loggerheads and
in constant tension.
And, and again, for me, that's just the Hegelian.
I mean, that, like, it's very familiar to me.
I understand that there's a basic opposition between these two fundamental forces, you know,
and they're in constant tension and transfer, you know, but I don't like that diagram.
Like that's not a diagram that is uncomfortable.
This is not going to solve it.
But I mean, one way to think of it is that the engine is the same for both ostensibly distinctive
forces, right?
So difference in identity or difference in sameness, although they are posed in an opposition very
explicitly in Hegel and in Derrida and whatever, the engine for the production of both separate
forces is the same engine, right?
So, or, or, or it's a simultaneous, well, again, the simultaneity, right?
Like you can't, if the opposition is constitutive, but difference is produced as its effect, right?
Like you'd have to think a simultaneity to those two.
I know.
I mean, I, I get it.
Like, even if you say, even if you say something like the engine is self-differentiation, you're
like, well, you already had a self, so I guess that's not really the engine, right?
Like, I mean, I get the pro, I get the problem in there.
I'm just not comfortable, you know, with that resolution.
And that is the resolution that is, I remember I faced that the final chapter of my, of the
invention book, um, was, yeah.
And it was on, and the way that it's always thought was the relation between tradition
and invention is seen as one that's intention.
And you can understand that makes sense.
Like new stuff versus old stuff.
Right.
And the, and the huge move for me conceptually in thinking through that was the old stuff
isn't old, right?
Like the old stuff is invented too.
And so therefore what, what has changed in that is there's no tension, right?
Or the, or rather the tension that one sees between those is secondary because one has
to produce the notion of a tension.
Like that has to, you has to generate a sense of the tradition, uh, that is opposed to innovation
in order to get that, like that the tradition isn't a given.
The tradition requires invention.
So for me in that deconstructive move, you'd say a different sense of invention is the condition
of possibility for the very distinction between invention and tradition.
And I feel like that's what I'm doing here is a different sense of difference, different,
difference as a kind of, I mean, I keep coming back to illocutionary performance.
That's always my word for it is like, that's the condition for the distinction between sameness
and difference that does enter us into the Hegelian dialectic.
And it does play out exactly that way.
I mean, I honestly take that to be his, uh, and, uh, oh, by the way, the other news item
to point out is that I am teaching a class on Derrida this spring.
So that's it.
Like, in fact, the course description is the title of the class is Derrida and the course
description is we will read stuff written by Derrida.
Excellent.
So, but currently there are two students enrolled, so I don't know if that'll make, but one of
the reasons that I, one of the reasons that I, cause I was talking about it with you guys
before, but one of the reasons I decided on was the pod, the podcast.
I was like, okay, so this is an aside, but one of the things that you guys got to do is
let's pick some text in the next few weeks.
Let's pick some texts that like I'm going to teach.
We don't have to read them all, but you know, but that's going to be coming up sooner rather
than later is all I'm saying.
But what I was going to say is I take that and that's one of the things that I'm interested
to do is sort of revisit Derrida on Heidegger, you know, and, um, and around that question,
cause that's my preliminary takeaway from stuff I read on Heidegger 20 years ago was he follows
the line of thinking completely except for the notion of the proper, right?
That that's the whole problem for him with Heidegger is this insistence on the proper.
Yeah.
You know, but, but I wouldn't say that he forces connections.
I do agree that he, I don't, and I wouldn't even say that he plays with them is that he
allows for a play of the play of relays that are already set out there.
That's right.
And that's why the word play is tricky, right?
Right.
I don't want to say that it's just, you know,
It's not in the lunatic, like Victor Vitenza way.
Right.
Like, I mean, you know, the first page of Plato's Pharmacy, you know, it begins with that kind
of like etymological, you know, overview of, yeah.
Slaphos, blow to the cheek, knock, slap, right?
And which, you know, like, which he also connects to writing.
And, you know, and he makes all of these connections, you know, over the course of the essay.
But I wouldn't say that he forces any of them.
He follows one and it leads to another and it leads to another.
And it doesn't create, it's not organized around a center and it's not organized around
an originary, but the circulatory system is not, that gets activated here is not, it's rigorously
produced.
It's not, it is not haphazardly produced.
Well, okay.
I agree.
Think about the etymology of haphazard, like there are elements of chance involved, right?
But, but not random.
The reason I say force, I mean, it's not like in the awkward sense.
I mean, I just kind of meant like appropriate, like it's an act.
It's, it's an act of appropriation explicitly as opposed to an act of discovery, right?
Like he pitches it that way.
Like, it's not like differance just fell into his lap.
He made that concept, you know, and it's a genius concept.
And all the little, you know, even the fucking accent and everything, it all has import and
value, but it's not like that just sort of appeared.
But Nate, did you not know it is not a concept?
Yeah.
This concept that is not a concept.
I actually feel like that's one of the, that kind of refrain is probably one of the reasons
that Derrida is so hated by so many analytical, like just having to always say, this is neither
an idea.
This is neither a word nor a concept.
It's like, shut the fuck up.
We got it.
Right.
We, we get the logic of the thinking, but like neither is anything.
So why do you have to keep pointing it out?
That and the, in the simple phrase, always already.
Always already.
Yeah.
Which again, I get the distinction.
Which is the name of a philosophy podcast, by the way.
Always already.
Not a bad, not a bad name for a pod.
Yeah.
I happened upon that one recently.
It's no, it's no Thinking With people.
No.
I listened to, um, Philosophize This on, um, Simone de Beauvoir and Nietzsche.
And the guy is smart.
Like, I like his take on it, but is this so incredible, have you either of you listened
to it?
It's so incredibly moralizing that he's pulling out like life lessons.
Yeah.
His version of Deleuze is terrible.
I imagine.
I haven't heard it.
It's a little basic.
I mean, he can be kind, he tries to be like funny, quippy a lot of the time.
I mean, he's whatever.
Oh, it's so forced though.
Yeah.
It's bad.
Uh, I like the, the guys that you mentioned the one time I listened to their stuff quite a
bit when I was doing some Nietzsche.
What's their, uh.
Um, that partially examines life.
Partially examined life.
That's a good, that's a good group of guys.
I like that one.
Yeah.
So they, they were all, um, they were all in a PhD department together.
Um, but they all, I think dropped, I think only one of them finished and they all kind
of got jobs in different places.
Right.
And part of, you know, what they explained that they didn't, what they didn't like about
it was the dogmatism.
Uh, but they still liked reading this stuff.
So they just started like, they've been doing it for several years now.
Yeah.
Um, and.
They have like pretty good product.
Yeah.
Like they've been doing it for quite some time and yeah, they'll just pick a text and they
won't stick with it nearly as long as we are.
No, they'll do two or three episodes maybe.
Yeah.
Like, well, like sometimes it'll be like four if it's a really, you know, hefty thing.
Right.
Um.
But they have a patient.
But it is much more exegetical.
It is much more like, what's the thing here?
And then, you know, oftentimes like how do we, you know, how, how is it critiquable?
Yeah.
And I do think like there are moments where they're doing, they're not just doing that,
but that is definitely the impulse.
Right.
It's good for like, if you want something a little better than philosophize this, like
they have actually pretty engaging conversations and I like it just as sort of a refresher on
certain thinkers.
is because like you can forget basic stuff with Foucault and Nietzsche and just to have
like them going through the main concepts.
I'm like, oh, well, I could just talk about Foucault's power.
I like forgot that he had that central concept as opposed to all these esoteric ones that I
was using.
We talk about the slowness that Heidegger interjects into rhythms of thought.
And I thought this was a good instance of that.
This is the top of 96.
He does not say against something temporal.
He does not say against some specific characteristic of time.
He says flatly revulsion against time.
Of course, the words and, uh, and it's, it was to follow directly.
That means, does it not against the, it was in time.
And he's so like, he's trying to say like, look, there's one way of reading this where
in the, the, the will's revulsion against time isn't against time as such.
It's just this one aspect of time, this pastness that it was.
And he, this is where Heidegger's like, we're going to do like, ah, it's not just that.
This is just straight up time or timing.
Time includes not only the past, but also the future and the present.
Nietzsche then by stressing that it was, does intend time in a particular respect and not
time as such in general.
But what about time?
After all, uh, it is not bundled in with the past, future and present are wrapped up together.
Time is not a cage in which the no longer now and the not yet now and that now are cooped
up.
How do matters stand with time?
This fucking phrase, by the way.
They stand thus.
Time goes.
I just wrote in the margin.
That's another one of my LOL moments.
I'm just like, fucking Heidegger.
This is such a you move.
That's so you, Heidegger.
Yeah.
They stand thus.
Time goes.
Yeah.
We don't have relationships with these texts.
It's just like, and what is the essential nature of an animal?
It is a beast.
But it's, but I just say like, that's something that you would say to a loved one.
Like, it's so you.
It's so you to say that.
Fuck you.
That's just Heidegger.
Right.
Heidegger being Heidegger again.
The passing of time is, of course, a coming, but a coming which goes, which goes in passing
away.
What comes in time comes to stay, but to go.
What comes in time always bears beforehand the mark of going past and passing away.
This is why everything temporal is regarded simply as what is transitory.
This is why that it was does not mention just one out of time's three sectors.
Rather, the true endowment which time gives and leaves behind is what has passed away, that
it was.
Time gives only what it has, and it has only what it is itself.
And so it's a way of, what I'm getting there is like, he's, in some ways, this is a demonstration
of a lot of what he's been talking about.
Like, you have to get yourself, you have to open up the passage to reveal its essential
quality.
This is a demonstration of kind of what he means by that is just talk about time and
it's, it was.
And, you know, in the next paragraph, maybe I'll read this in a second.
He talks about that conjunction there.
It's not just adding something on by, as a way of getting at this, that essential notion
of time as a process that instantiates moments of, of, of, of passings into moments.
And it doesn't matter if that happened in the past or will happen in the future or as
a now, it is the operation of the demarcation that, you know, that, that, that will reviles
against and reviles against itself.
And this is what I'm just starting to put together right now is why, you know, I first, I had
this in the back of my head, like why in the world would the will be revolted by this?
This seems to be its exact operation to demarcate.
And it doesn't make sense to say that this is a limit of the demarcation, demarcating power
of the will.
It's exactly the power of the will to demarcate, to create moments, to create events, to create
things, to, to do, um, deploy these metaphysical operations, uh, except for the fact that, uh,
oh shit, now I just lost it.
I had, it was like, oh, I was on the fucking mountaintop.
Oh, you almost, yeah, you were almost there.
In, in, in a cave, but I'm going to try to talk my way, my way through it.
That's all right.
It's like the will, the real, the will reviles itself, its own mechanism.
Yeah, the will reviles against its own, it's, the, the, it reviles against its own capacity
to do that.
Right.
Yeah.
I mean, it, it doesn't want to be an appropriation machine, which it sort of is.
Right.
Encountering otherness is encountering something that is not yet will.
And so that's the sense in which the, it was, is like, what do I do with this?
It's a limit.
I, I've encountered a limit.
It's very Hegelian.
Yeah.
And the notion that there was a you or a part of you that is no longer you.
Right.
That's the ultimate, like, terror of the movement of time.
It's the passing.
I mean, that, that's where, like, it was, is not just one of time's free modalities.
The passing away is what time is.
Right.
Like, and so it's the, it's the passing away, the it was-ness, even though the, it's not yet
happened for the future, it's the it was-ness that is the sort of target of, of the will's
revulsion.
So he says, like, right below where you're reading, revenge is the will's revulsion against
time, and that means against the passing away and its past.
Right.
The passing away quality of time, the becoming present only as a past sort of frozen artifact.
That, that limits, like, the will loves the future, right, because anything's available
and possible.
Right, right.
Yeah.
But no, the it was would still have to be the future.
Right.
Because futures are nothing more, but future it was.
But that's the changed version.
That's the, the, the thing.
So the will initially, the spirit of revenge version of the will, which is what innervates
the will at this stage, because we haven't gotten to the eternal return moment, but the,
you know, the will, it feels, finds itself limited by the past, because that's just what
was.
Right.
What can I, what can I do with the past?
The past is the past, right?
There's no possibilities for will there.
There's no demarcation.
There's no appropriate.
There's nothing I can do.
It's just, it's already happened and has passed.
So it's the, the act of passing away that the will experiences a limitation for itself.
Right.
Yeah.
See, I was reading that differently, and I just feel like I'm so out of sync with what
I was thinking before, but I can at least throw this part out there, is that it doesn't,
I wasn't taking this that the will reviles becoming or the passing away, because that would
be, that would animate, I mean, that spirit of revenge, like revulsion and revenge are different,
right?
So it exercises revenge on the passing away, on the pure movement of time, of becoming, but
then it is simultaneously revolted by its own, its own operation of timing, of making, uh,
times and moments.
Creating moments of presence and nowness, right?
Like that's, that's what the will does is it creates presence.
And it reviles against that as well.
But it can't do, no, no, no.
But it can't do that with the past.
It can't do that with things that are past, that have passed away, right?
It's, or that's at this phase of the thinking, it can't do that.
The past is just, the past is just the past.
What can I do with the past?
It has happened, right?
I, I, I don't, I can't exercise my operation of delimiting, controlling, freezing.
It's been frozen, right?
It's been done.
Yeah, but, but it, just to say it like that would be to differentiate the past from the
present in, in a way that I think Heidegger is really trying to prevent where the, what
is reviled against is time and time is only that it was.
The passing away.
It's passing.
Right.
Time is only the passing away.
I mean, the, you know, we try to think in terms of the now, I mean, what, what he ends
up doing is say, like, what's the past?
The past is a bunch of nows that you can't do anything with, right?
Like, I mean, so the, the past is a now that's frozen.
It doesn't get to make it.
I'm seeing an important difference between passing away and it was.
The it was is a part of time that has been carved out.
Passing away is a, there's no demarcation to it.
It's just the perpetual passing away.
So what, you know, time is beyond us.
We just say time and becoming are the same thing in a sense.
And the will takes revenge upon that by, by demarcating moments of it.
And those moments are the, it was, and it frankly doesn't matter if those, it was, is
are in what we would call the past or in what we would call the now or what we would call
the future.
Does that make sense?
So it's the, it's the action of, or the active action of making something present that matters.
And what happens when you make something present is it becomes the past, right?
Like it instantly does.
And then there's a, but there's a revulsion then to it having become the past, which is the,
that's the, the passing away is a, it's, it's both the condition for the will's action and the thing that it can't stand.
Right.
So even when I encapsulate a bit of what we would commonplace call the future.
I don't feel good about it.
It immediately becomes a past and I can't do anything with it.
And I can't do anything with it anymore.
And that's why I reviled it.
So it's, it's, so in a sense it is, that's why it's internal to the will.
It's the will's internal problem with itself.
Yeah.
It just, it, it wants to make presences, but it can't do anything with presences that are already passed.
It made them into presences.
Right.
Which in other words, it's just another way of saying it can't, like if the, if the will is pure in the way it only wants to do the same thing over and over and over and over and over again.
It can't do what it, it can't exert that will on what it's already willed.
That's right.
Exactly.
Which is why it's a revulsion with itself.
It's, it's, it's disgusted by what it's already pooped out.